what
half the time when i watch the sequences
like this i'm just like oh my goodness
so much work i'm willing to bet some of
that light on them is actually from real
life
rather than from the volume you know
i mean this is quite famous for being
not that great there's no way to get
that right how would you ever get that
right
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video and stick around at the end if you
want to know how you can get three
months free
hey what is up everybody welcome back to
the effects artist react i'm i'm back
i'm joining you guys dude you told the
arnold
i'm back and i'm bad
joe farrell is back as well he is the
vfx supervisor on xiangchi he did
transformers he did wolf of wall street
i robot a bunch of other awesome movies
you definitely have seen so we're
excited to be here with you joe yeah
glad to be here i'm almost becoming a
regular yeah pretty much let's do it
let's jump in
so i believe in one of the earliest
episodes of vfx irish react we looked at
the scene but it's been a few years and
i really think it'd be a good idea to
kind of revisit this shot
here's a sequence that by all intents
and purposes is incredible and yet i
feel like most people seeing this don't
have that sort of impression i mean
there's some beautiful work in here
absolutely half the time when i watch
sequences like this i'm just like oh my
goodness so much work what i'm noticing
through this whole sequence here is that
the thing that is not working the most
is the compositing the renders of the
dinosaurs the renders of all of the
foliage and leaves and stuff like that
even all the rocks in my opinion
especially for 2005 looks pretty dang
great but the integration of the live
action footage there's that oftenness
about it like oh like right there it
just looks like a classic james bond
rear projection type situation where
that disconnect is very apparent
that last shot i think there appears to
be no breakup in the shadow of the
dinosaur that's a really strange one
because you can see his shadow his
shadow is pretty sharp there's just
something about the dinosaur having a
shadow that sharp that just doesn't fly
that and the fact that it didn't deform
over the tree there's plenty of examples
where vfx is forced to create a shadow
on something that's not lit with that
shadow in mind the sorting hat in harry
potter is a classic example you see
harry potter sitting there and he's got
some sort of sunlight from the stage
lighting on him and they're just like oh
well i'll just pull that down in comp
unfortunately light falling on a human
skin is very very complex as you know
you've spoken about on numerous of your
shows subsurface scattering specular
highlights and all of that stuff is
subconsciously programmed into our brain
the audience who watches this don't
realize but they're all incredibly good
visual effects judges so basically you
can't put a shadow over yeah man this is
so tough i feel like the only way to get
this right is to just do everything cg
yeah it's a tricky one because they're
shooting in sunlight you want to shoot
them in sunlight but if you didn't shoot
them in sunlight you wouldn't have that
extreme differences where you need to
put a shadow over something that's
brightly lit like you'd be better off
shooting in a slightly flat light and
then maybe upping you could put more
sunlight into it the biggest problem
when i was going to come and talk to you
guys about it is shooting an outdoor
scene indoors most of the time it's rare
for you to be able to shoot outdoor
scenes in a controlled environment
because you just don't have control over
the elements but the problem is is when
you shoot a daylight sun lit environment
you can only do so much with the
sunlight in a stage for instance you can
be on the biggest stage and you can put
this massive light to represent the sun
but it's always not going to be parallel
lines of sunlight so the sunlight will
hit the guy on the left and the lady on
the right differently and your eye is
good enough to pick up on it yeah it's
like slightly different angles because
it's a point source emanating outwards
and unless that point source is millions
of miles away there's going to be a
little bit of angle variation and like
you're saying it's like it's subtle but
your eyes pick up on it to me to do all
that stuff right there where they're
running underneath and there's just
shifting shadows and a billion different
variables coming off of every single
little point there's no way to get that
right how would you ever get that right
here's what's happening you're seeing a
combination of assets so what you're
seeing is with the dinosaur they
probably spent six months of r d making
that dinosaur work somebody's done r d
on the rubble and they've spent six
months developing it and they're able to
push out these amazing elements so the
dinosaur will look great the rocks will
look good but what's happening is all of
those elements that are being pushed
through a render pipeline which is being
squeezed left right and center that's
all coming through at different times
and so what happens is it ends up being
put onto the compositor's lap and they
get nine days but then what's happening
also while you're comping is elements
are updating and sometimes
the the shot will go in for an effects
review and the director will change you
know there's more rubble here but remove
all the rubble over here with the laser
pointer so what happens is the comp
artist now gets a new rock pass and all
the rocks that they had made look good
over here are now not there anymore
they're over here and now they've got
like a day to turn it around yeah what
happens is the compositing department
everything is just thrown at them and
they do what they can to do it and if
you give them the time they'll make gold
but if you don't and you end up with
shots that are just unfortunate
oh this one's not so good oh man he's
gliding there's some physics from here
she's there if you were like okay it
didn't work how would we redo it this
would be a pretty hard one to do yeah it
was one of those situations i feel like
all of these elements are executing at a
very high level but it comes down to
asking too much from the compositing
team yeah not from just like in terms of
time but literally raw ability you can't
just add shadows to a person's face lit
in sunlight and try to make it look like
they're in not sunlight you know you
can't just remove that from a real-life
plate trying to do it the best you can
is going to just inevitably only get so
far and that's going to stand out when
everything else is an a-plus like you're
saying there's so many variables
involved with the actual production
itself that it's like you get through it
as best you can just to have something
well the other thing is to think about
when they're working on a show like this
there's two and a half thousand shots
and i think pretty much all of this was
done at weta now imagine the size of the
compositing team so you might have
150 compositors and it's really to do
with the skill set from the compositors
so you're going to have a range of
skills from somebody who's just learning
how to come from somebody who's like a
veteran who's been doing it for 20 years
and so what happens is some of these
shots you look at them and you'll be
like ah that looks pretty good yeah and
then you look at some other ones and
they're like uh what happened well what
happened is they probably ran out of
time and they had 350 shots to turn
around in probably two and a half weeks
nobody starts out with the goal of
making bad visual effects it's
circumstances that gets handed to you
and i think unfortunately visual effects
has a bad rap because any time people
see it they go oh that looks bad but
that's the problem is because you saw it
you think therefore it's bad i guarantee
you if you were to see some of the
projects that i've worked on if you saw
what we actually doing to it it would
boggle your mind like we are successful
like 80 of the time all you see is the
20 which we struggled on for these
reasons it's kind of like taking a test
and the only passing grade is an a yes
yeah that's exactly it it's basically if
we if you looked at the ratio if let's
say you had 100 shots and 87 of them
were you didn't realize were there
that's a pretty good score in math you
know if you're getting like 87 90 people
like wow they're really good but
unfortunately you see that 10 in visual
effects and the audience is like yeah
it's crap
is that paul marty it's paul gmardi
classic floating head scenarios oh it
looks weird because i can't imagine how
he would fit in there
what he's like
he's like this he's like he's folding
backwards yeah he's like he's like he's
like a mermaid he's in full mermaid
stance what you don't realize is he's
wearing spandex under there that's right
i figured he just lubes up before he
gets into the rhino
again it's a classic example of
decisions happening afterwards they're
creating these shadows i see it i see
already because i know that they
actually shot him in like this crazy
physical buck on set but now they have
this whole contraption above his head
blocking the harsh sunlight you probably
read the script you went we'll shoot it
like this and then you see the concept
design you go that design will work well
so we'll design a buck that will look
like this and then you shoot it like
this and it looks great but there's
probably something happening there's
like well it's not tough enough we've
screened it and it's like we need to
change the design for this this and this
and so the problem is you're now asking
the compositor to make that head sit in
a completely different thing and maybe
they changed the light maybe they shot
it in an overcast scenario and then
maybe they wanted it to be suddenly in
sunlight if you had a really good
version of the digital version of paul g
marty's head there's a chance that you
could actually project his face onto the
model and redo the shadows but again
it'll boil down to the specular
highlight on his head and the subsurface
scattering that's happening on the
shadow i mean i can see that they
actually are trying you can see the very
bright specular highlight on the front
of his forehead actually kind of dim
down pretty intensely as the shadow goes
across it is but what's happening is the
his head is so bright that it doesn't
reflect the brightness of the cg render
the way i would fix this is i would
brighten up that left side i would over
expose the left side if that brought up
more it would actually justify his
bright side and then the shadow side of
it is sort of a bit too like it's
strangely deep and dark directly behind
his back
and he's like bounce yeah
so it means a little bit of ambient in
there i'd bring it up and then there's
that weird it's almost like a fresnel
falloff that's happening on him so this
is the kind of thing that maybe this
happened right at the last second and
maybe the poor team that's working on it
were working their tails off trying to
get it done this is slightly ironic
because we're always saying if you're
going to be shooting someone outside but
against a green screen make sure that
you're actually shooting it outside
which they did here but as always there
are additional problems that come about
that you kind of really got to know
ahead of time to solve
[Music]
if you're not subscribed to this channel
already what the heck are you doing hit
the subscribe button you know where it
is
[Music]
if you've got magic hour what happens is
that light only exists for like a 15
minute window yeah in real life right so
if you were standing in a real city you
just can't shoot it and so the best
scenario for that is to shoot it onto a
volume and they do amazing things i'm
gonna find him and i'm gonna make him
pay you're gonna help me help you yeah
she's getting beautiful lighting down
here the bat suit looks fantastic i'm
willing to bet some of that light on
them is actually from real life
rather than from the volume you know
people think that like oh you get the
leds going up and it's gonna project
light onto your subjects and it's like
yes but a lot less than you might
realize all the lighting that you're
actually seeing on their edges there is
probably from an actual light like these
just blasting them what you're gaining
out of here is reflections the top of
his shoulders are picking up the sky led
and here he's quite reflective yes it's
a light source but it's all about
reflections on him they would be very
very expensive if you needed to do those
in post you're like oh why is it not
quite right uh you know this is an
excellent scenario and the reason it's
good is because the environment that
they're in that volume that they're in
it's not significantly changing so what
happens is on a volume you you'll move
the camera you get this perspective
change and when all the pieces are lined
up you get a great subject they're
receiving the reflections the
background's changing and then the next
day you can change it out and you all
come back to the same stage all the
logistics are all the same but now
you're in a different location very very
cool the problem is in order to create
that asset that's running on the game
engine that works in real time required
three months worth of a team of 20
people working on it and people seem to
forget that and the problem is is when
you do create it it needs to be right
for camera on the day and if you didn't
make it right for the day you can't
change it because it's built in so now
what you've got is you've got a let's
say you later on you realize you're like
oh the building changed well now you've
burnt it in you now need to roto them
out yeah you've spent an enormous amount
of money getting to that stage with the
volume and now you need to redo it so
the volume is basically all the work
that you'd be doing after you shoot in
post you're kind of taking a big chunk
of that work and you're kind of doing it
before you shoot yeah so the cool thing
is is you get to do it in camera so it
works really well when you like shoot
photography like we're definitely going
to be in gotham we're definitely going
to be a sunset it's going to look like
this so you get this sort of like known
entities what happens is when you do
moving things or the buildings or
anything like that you don't know what
it's going to look like in the edit so
it sounds like a very specific use case
scenario i have mixed opinions about the
volume i'll tell you that the volume is
like vr it's like they're building them
all around the world it's a really cool
tool it does certain things really well
but we're not going to spend our entire
lives living in vr it shouldn't be like
a this is a done and we're shooting on
volumes from now on and as a consequence
you know there's some things that it
doesn't work for and it looks worse than
if you'd have shot it on a blue so is
the price of making a magic hour scene
like this worth it and in this case yes
it is
[Music]
mr president it's time to get you off
this play
that's got to be like a real miniature
model it's a real miniature model it's
all done with model work model works
brilliant i love going back to that sort
of style i think people really
appreciate it and we're trying to do a
lot of practical there's a strange
suspension of disbelief that happens
it's like i'm willing to accept the fact
that that's real and i'm invested in the
story but i know that is fake and made
by people that are on set i think
there's more like weight to it the more
that's real the more the movie is
actually happening in my mind at least
you know i think in visual effects we're
always trying to reach that goal and the
best method of doing it you know for
years we would see puppets and real
practical things in movies and so we
kind of just got used to seeing that and
accepting that as real and so when you
have a show like the mandalorian come
out and you know little baby yoda grogu
who's a puppet in a lot of shots but
also digital a lot more often than most
people realize but they designed the
digital version of the puppet to look
like the real puppet and that sells it
so much more than just like oh actually
he would really look like this if he's a
real creature it's like no they're not
making a creature they're making a
puppet
there's definitely a real sequence
because at one point this happens
and that's a real dude in real air with
a real plane
right that pumps goodness
and then this i mean this is quite
famous for being not that great and you
know people being pulled out of film
this one is definitely pulling you out
of a film so i don't want anybody
complaining about water work anymore
because
people could have this kind of work
if they think this is better then we can
go back to that that was all cg but it
looked like there was four wow
it's a real model i think they're doing
real model and they're breaking it up
probably or they're doing some kind of
camera work around it and then they've
shot a plate of the ocean way before it
was ready for prime time they've
probably tried to do some digital
marriage between those two but oh man
yeah they would have known that that
wasn't working when they were making
that like they would just be like
it's what we got handed a half the time
when we look at bad vfx there's always a
story to be told about why it's bad but
you know sometimes you can actually do
good visual effects but it takes no more
time and even if you only had two weeks
if you just did this that it would be
better off a better result than what you
ended up doing those are the kind of
things that kind of you know i try and
yeah some effects are completely
irrelevant to time
yes guys
i regret to inform you that my list of
things to look at is starting to run dry
i need your help what are some things
that we should look at leave a comment
down below i'll check them out because i
need them
hey guys i did a bad vfx shot so they
sent us me to the hole for three days
now normally it's mind-numbingly boring
in this room but this time i snuck in my
laptop and thanks to expressvpn i could
go anywhere on the world wide web and
we'll know about it without a vpn
hackers and third parties can pop in
whenever they'd like and start mining
your data your passwords your personal
information and your browsing history
not that the last one should scare you
but if it does
well not to mention without a vpn you're
limiting the amount of content you have
access to like did you know that in
england they have different shows on
netflix than the us then canada than
india there's different shows out there
that you're probably not even aware of
like there could be another rrr just
waiting to be seen by those ojos and you
don't even know like the sad kid who's
stuck eating a wet old tuna fish
sandwich while all the other kids have
lunchables and fruit by the foot well
with a vpn you get to choose the food
you want from the lunch pail of every
kid in the world in the same way i have
access to this contraband pilot chips
cheers
no food in the hole
tell netflix you're in canada for
example and you have instant access to
one of my personal favorites the
disaster artist shout out tell me we sew
i actually have a
autographed speedo by the man so
now they know in today's world there's
no reason not to use a vpn it gives you
access to parts of the internet that
were previously untouchable and protects
your data from would-be hackers thieves
and those darn peeps and toms keep those
tom's peepers out of my dang data yeah i
said dang
yeah i'm getting pretty wild in here
thanks again to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video and if you want to
lock your data up the way jake locked me
up in this room head on over to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew for three months free
all right see you guys later now back to
the video
i i feel like i learned a lot today
because you've got all of the experience
from what it actually means to create
this stuff and so thank you so much for
providing a lot of that context to show
us how hard it really is to make movies
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you for having me ryan it was
awesome i really enjoyed talking with
you guys sam and of course thanks to you
for watching we really appreciate it
we'll see you next saturday